for Mohammad Shah FIBA there should be a
happy time
his family's apple crop is looking good
this season and will be ready for
harvesting in September but the region's
lockdown has made it hard to get
supplies and laborers from outside are
being told to stay out the laborers from
outside Kashmir the government told them
to go home
pesticides we can't get because the
markets are shut rice vegetables we
can't even get meat for ourselves
because everything is shut that's
affecting people with small businesses
especially in farming were worried the
restrictions on communication and
movement means their hard work will be
thrown away it's a situation that's
common throughout the Kashmir Valley but
most businesses staying shut in Srinagar
carpet sellers have already stocked up
for both the tourists and wedding season
this month but few have had any sales
and weeks so many employees overhead
they belong to poor families we help
them then we have no sales how can we
houseboat hotels on Srinagar famous Dal
Lake sit empty and with only local
people riding a few of the gondolas many
boatman are fishing to pass the time and
catch a meal just before the
restrictions earlier this month the
government ordered tourists to leave the
area taking with them one vital piece of
the region's economy but it's not the
first time kashmiris have suffered from
work and businesses being shut down has
a devastating impact we know but there
are goals above and our economy they
have abandoned their work they know
there are tourism their fruits is and
everything is at stake but they know
that their existence their culture and
their landscape everything is at stake
bot doesn't know if he'll be allowed to
transport his crop to market or find
enough trucks to do so but he'll
continue tending his fields because for
many here culture and pride are more
important than business and money as
Jameel al jazeera show pian district
indian-administered Kashmir